so this is the 10 minute speed run
um which is going to be a climb from the
beginner level
to approximately 2000 to 2200
um but this time we're playing 10 minute
games
rather than five minute games the
motivation behind this we play very
aggressively with white
very positionally with black so i'll
i'll play subs
maybe a little bit later but right now
i'm just playing the general pool
because i'm playing at the rating that i
currently am
um and we uh
you know we discuss more during the game
so that the post game
analyses are more targeted toward
people's questions um
and you know sometimes i'll talk about
stuff that i talked about in the five
minute speed run
but i'll also try to very vary the
conversation vary the types of openings
we play so hopefully we'll get a chance
to talk about new stuff thank you the
overtaker
um and uh without further ado let's go
ahead and play
a 10-minute game you guys ready
[Music]
let's go caesar alonso one so we're
playing with the white pieces
now we're gonna play e4 most of the
games and the opening that i have been
experimenting with we played this
yesterday nobody actually accepted this
gambit
uh but that is the danish gamut the
danish gambit is definitely
a full-fledged weapon for for beginners
it's a great
opening to teach you about how the
pieces work
and you can obviously score some quick
wins okay so b6
by my opponent is not a you know not not
a great move he's turning it into a
gambit himself
um and there's no reason that we don't
want to just take this pawn
um i assume he wants to fianchetto his
bishop
i assume okay so f6 is
i mean he's sort of playing kind of like
a a danish gambit on the other side of
the board now f6 is a very weakening
move
uh because it weakens the diagonal two
blacks king
and one of the big temptations that
people have
when they face a move like f6 is to
deliver this check immediately queen h5
check
why is quinn h5 not as effective as it
looks though and what should we do
thank you mila ciar for the for the
prime yeah so the reason is that black
can block with his pawn and force the
queen back
it's too early does that mean quinn h5
is
uh not useful absolutely not it might
become useful
in many different circumstances so
instead we should not overthink it
you know the pawn on e5 it's not really
hanging due to the threat of queen h5
um and that's actually a pretty
important detail
so bishop c4 looks like an amazing move
to actually exploit another weakness
that f6 has
uh the weakening of this diagonal which
will
make it impossible in the long term for
black to castle right because the bishop
covers the g8 square that would become
illegal
um julia one one if you're a beginner
chances are you've heard the principle
nights before bishops
um and you might look at this and say
well aren't you violating that
how did you know that here you should
develop your bishop first well the logic
is
uh he's played a move like f6 which is
sort of beyond the pale
and for that reason um
that necessitates a change of our
approach and we actually have a really
cool idea here
now 97 is is he's trying to develop his
pieces
but now he's allowing a really cool
combination queen h5 check
and i hope he plays g6 that'll allow us
to play a really cool move
knight g6 here would actually be
relatively speaking the best move
yes he's got g6 so what idea am i
thinking of guys
very pretty main how do i even see this
in the first week the moment he played
97
i'm looking at his king and i'm saying
that his king is
um his king
is devoid of squares thank you the red
eye jedi tv it has no squares and the
knight is just taking away its final
square
the bishop takes away the f7 square so
immediately
i'm starting to think about potential
mates and because we have a pawn on e5
i'm just seeing
that this pawn could land on f7 and so
that's why
we induced g6 now the pawn on f6 loses
its support
and we might get a chance to deliver the
pawn made i'm assuming he takes the
queen yep and f7 is made very nice
that's kind of a cool name i lie always
i always like pond mates
um so well that was a nice one
so e4 e5 d4 nobody
has actually taken the pawn yet nobody
has accepted the danish gambit we faced
knight c6
we faced ed and then c5 this guy plays
b6
um and after d takes e5 the best
approach for black would have been
to follow through with bishop b7
obviously black is no compensation for
the fun
okay so f6 and now bishop c4
um so what exactly would we have done in
the event of f take c5 who can tell me
the most precise idea here for white and
white is several good moves
but there is sort of a classic
refutation
to uh something like this which occurs
in other positions and that is
so knight f3 is fine of course but we
can win the game with queen h5
so what has changed from from this
position right what has changed
well the only thing that's changed is
that the pawn has landed on e5 and
paradoxically
the fact that black spawn is now on e5
rather than white spawn is actually in
white's favor because after queen h5 g6
queen takes e5 forks the great king in
the rook this is a very common tactical
theme
in many different types of openings
particularly in an opening called the
damiano
which i've talked about before that's
where after knight f3 black plays the
move f6 immediately
and as some of you may know white has
knight takes c5 very famous
sacrifice that's been around since 17th
century
and the idea is to position black's pawn
on e5 in order to pick it off with a
fork
this literally is as old as the hills so
it's the same kind of concept here
of course in a slightly different
slightly different clothing
and if the king moves up then this is
literally checkmate
and that's part of the reason the bishop
is so so good here okay
so he goes 97 and now we go queen h5
check
um and once again always look at your
opponent's king in these situations
and in the moment that the king has no
squares you need to start looking at
potential checkmating configurations
eventually if you solve a lot of puzzles
your brain will do
will do this for you i don't need to
turn the engine on kind of thing it goes
into the gear
automatically right the transmission is
automatic i know to look for this
because i've seen a million patterns
like this before some other mate type
ideas
but if you're new to chess or if you
don't have as much experience you don't
need to feel
embarrassed to tell yourself this okay
now i need to look for mates
and it takes a long time for this to
become automatic so queen h5 check
g6 he takes f6 and he's absolutely
busted because we're threatening the
night with threatening mate
uh had he gone knight g6 ryan smith
thank you the best thing to do would
have just been to develop our night and
to develop the other night in castle and
we're
absolutely dominating here because he
cannot castle like
basically ever because the bishop covers
the g8 square
okay so there's nothing extraordinary
that i had cooked up here oh there's
actually one thing we can do
thanks anu there's actually one thing we
can do let's let's say it makes a random
look now i'm looking at this pin right
and in the first speeder and i talked
frequently about um
a way of categorizing or classifying
pins by how dangerous they are
the bottom line is that there is a pawn
defending the pinned piece
and i i made a funny i think i don't
think this is actually a word but
i call the knight the pin piece and then
the king is the penny
like you know like hunter hunty um it's
not a real word but that's a good way to
keep straight the two components of a
pen this is the pinner
the king is the penny the piece that is
on the opposite end
and then the knight or whatever pieces
in the middle is the pinned piece
right the knight is the piece that is
pinned and if the pin piece is defended
by a pawn
it's a lot safer most of the time than a
pin piece that's not defended by a pawn
that doesn't mean you can't put pressure
on a pin piece even if it's defended by
a pawn
and uh you have a crushing idea knight
h4 yeah knight h4
and you're not trying to win the night
it's what what makes this crushing is
the fact that black is a rook on a tree
that's undefended and
this entire construction falls apart you
can take on g6 and give may you can also
take the rook
this is just a very one-sided stuff okay
um so you have to look for this kind of
stuff when you're pinning
uh a piece to the king and when the king
is this exposed lpdo type two that's
right
um and i'll talk about that a little bit
later okay any questions about this game
we'll definitely be able to sneak
another one in attacker and attackee
any questions ladies and gentlemen and
again i say this yesterday questions are
great
um please don't feel like oh people are
going to think you're weak or
you people know that you're a beginner
we're here to learn chances are
if you have a question you're not sure
whether to ask it a lot of people have
the same question
um you know try i know you have jobs
stuff that you do a lot better than i do
this is like we're not here to uh to
posture and to compare ratings
um so totally i mean as long as it's a
good faith
question you can feel free to ask it
is it better to accept or decline the
danish so the best line against the
danish i won't reveal it just yet
but the best thing to do is to accept
both pawns actually to take on
on v2 and now there's a disconnect
between what
um some books recommend and what i think
the best variation actually is i do need
to analyze this to
tell you for sure but i think this check
on before according to the computer
is the best move and then you know the
theory is very complicated black is
better here if he plays very accurately
but obviously um that shouldn't stop you
from playing the danish the fact that
the computer evaluates it a certain way
should by no means enter into your
considerations at all
until you're like 16 1700.
um well queen e7 here
would would not fix the underlying
problem which is that black is
underdeveloped and
i would actually invite black to take
the pawn and yesterday i introduced
this notion a little bit cheesy but
again i call this gambit mentality
gambit mentality is when you're not only
just like
sacrificing the pawn that you're
supposed to sacrifice
uh to play the gambit but you're ready
to sacrifice more than just that initial
pawn
um in order to play in the spirit of the
gambit so it would be very inconsistent
here to say oh no you know my pawns on
e4 is attacked
let's play queen takes d4 if you want to
have that mentality fine but don't play
the gamut in the first place you have to
be consistent in how you're approaching
the position
okay um so and by the way
the classical move in this position that
is recommended that has been recommended
for
over 100 years is d5 sacrificing back
one of the pawns in order to open up and
pave the way
for rapid more rapid development and
this leads to its own theory
we'll talk about it later let's jump
into the next game unless there are any
other questions um
[Music]
okay